on this episode superstar dual stops by
[Music]
[Music]
this is
Carrie be
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 237 of the askgaryvee
show and I'm excited duel I'm super
pumped he decided to join the show thank
you so much for coming
jewel I met the other day we had a great
kind of business chat and hit it off and
she went to the Knicks game
I brought tremendously bad luck that was
the worst Knicks game I've ever been to
in my life that was not me it happened
to be star player that didn't show up
and I guess I can disappear but uh but
uh I was really excited to do the show
obviously you guys know I've gone to the
call in formats on this show but I
decided for this we'll bring back the
classic style we've got five questions
with Andy over here and before we get
into the questions Jules for the four
people that may not know who you are
once you give a little context of a
little bit about your career and who you
are shares my name is Jules my real name
and even my real taste nobody asks me
that I just thought I'd throw it out
there I'm from Alaska my family were
pioneers I grew up on a homestead which
means I grew up eating on me what I
could kill or kin so my fame came in
really handy it didn't actually
it taught me resilience to taught me
grit it taught me how to grind it taught
me self-esteem from the inside out which
is being able to understand that you're
capable because you've been given the
opportunity to struggle which is a real
blessing and I ended up moving out of
fifteen ended up homeless at 18 with
Sharples why'd you why'd you really move
out at 15 my dad was abusive and so I
decided I would just live in a cabin by
myself we've been pretty transient moved
around a lot and taking care myself
quite a long time if I wanted to do it
on my own without something the cabin
besides myself so too young to drive I
would say checking in to work at a
pretty young age working multiple jobs
where in Homer Alaska and then I got a
scholarship to an amazing art school and
around about way in Michigan I was able
to graduate from high school yummy and
most importantly if I look back on my
life I knew that at 15 I should have
been a statistic
I knew that girls like me boys like me
even
in depth repeating the cycle that were
raised by and I didn't want to be a
statistic and so my life's mission
became this idea of nature versus
nurture and if you received bad nurture
can you get to know your real nature and
how do you return to yourself and so my
entire life's work has been that my
songs have been a side effect of that
and my next chapter of my life will be
more about that yeah that next chapter I
think what is what brought us to these
two seeds obviously you reached out and
and we we had a great talk and I was
completely blown away honestly after you
left I said the guy's like wow the
entrepreneurial understanding the
emotional intelligence there's so much
stuff that you know we come from very
couple different backgrounds we have
different lives but there's so much
stuff that you were talking about that I
was like wow like I get it and like I
believe in it and I was really excited
about the meeting and I think the
self-esteem stuff the internal emotional
strength but but what completely blew me
away and why I wanted you on the show as
well is with all the things like
meditation and emotional intelligence
and a lot of the things that we clicked
on I was and I want everybody know you
know I'm a tough-ass filter on this I
was really taken aback by your know how
the market and consumer behavior and
business savviness and it was really
interesting to me do you ever think of
yourself do you think of yourself as an
entrepreneur at all yes I think I've
handled my entire career very
entrepreneurial II when I was homeless I
ended up homeless for about a year when
I was 18 I turned down the advances of
my boss and when I wouldn't have sex
with him he wouldn't give me my paycheck
and so I thought no big deal I live in
my car for a couple months and get back
on my feet
but then the car I was living in got
stolen and so that's how I ended up
homeless and I started having panic
attacks began shoplifting a lot and I
realized I was going to end up in jail
or dead in short order and more
importantly when I was feeling something
one day I cut an image of myself in the
mirror and I realized I was a statistic
I didn't beat the odds
my goal of 15 three short years later I
was there and so I remembered the saying
that Buddha had said happiness doesn't
depend on who you are or what you have
it depends on what you think and so I
doubled down on serving out what I was
thinking and Descartes said I think
therefore I am
if I could rephrase that just a little
bit I would say I perceive what I think
therefore I am
if you can perceive you're sad to
something other than sad if you can
perceive your anxiety or something other
we are the observer that's an amazing
thing and so I began to develop
mindfulness exercises to help me
understand and have a better
relationship with showing up now because
fear is a thief and it takes the past
and a projection into the future and at
Robbie is the only opportunity you have
to create change I needed to create
change or else I was going to go down
the toilet
so I began developing these mindfulness
exercises what do you call them because
the term mindful wasn't even really
around them right what did you call them
do you remember I didn't have a word I
didn't tell anybody about understood
them how do know about it have you read
something like what impacted you at that
early age to understand to start my
slang term would be hacking the brain by
putting yourself in that mental place
episode people always ask me so many
things that I'm always stunned of how
much it's so insular I don't consume
other stuff I I don't know but it was so
there but how do you know that similar
things was very intuitive the exercise
was a camera for intuitive but I've read
I had a teacher that started getting in
Greek philosophy and I was about 15 on
the cover of my first album I have a
quote on the very front of it and it
says what we call human nature and
actualities human habit I began to look
at the idea that if my brain is
addictive can you get addicted to
healthy things instead of negative
things I'm studying habit loops and
replacing negative behaviors with
positive ones
so all these exercises that starts
developing for myself were strictly to
get through my day to manage my anxiety
and they worked and at the end of the
year I felt so much happier even though
I was homeless and so when record label
started coming to me I knew this and why
did they come for you did you have
something pop like it was there anything
that sparked the first batch of people
coming to I got a gig in a coffee shop
it was going out of business in San
Diego at the time all of the coffee
shops asked you to pay them to sing
there which was shocking I grew up bar
singing like this coffee shop oh yeah
good yeah I grew up singing in bars as
my dad where we got paid something and
so I was shocked in Southern California
where they wanted you to pay them for
the honor of letting people talk while
you
thank so I found there's actually a
woman who owned a coffee shop and I
played there with my friend he had a
following I didn't and at the end I went
to settle out and she goes no you keep
the tip money and I was like what are
you talking about my friend has brought
in 200 people and she goes you keep the
tip my name is it oh ok that's fine why
don't I keep all of your student coffee
fields we'll swap
it's all good with me she looked at me
like no thank you
and she's like you can take the tip
money or leave when I said you keep your
freaking took money and I walked out my
cursed her I didn't cuss but I stuck my
finger in her face nice I didn't fail
I said you're stealing from the people
that have been you put her out of
business monthly I put her out of
business mentally I am a witch and yes
you heard it and in and so they're like
oh [ __ ] she was she said I was feeling
principal and that noise would go there
No so I found a coffee shop that was
going out of business
and I said hey before you close your
doors give me two weeks and give me all
the door money and you can handle the
coffee in sales and food and so we
struck a deal and I suddenly had to go
out and get a following and I had to
write a bunch of songs because I grew up
singing cover song because my dad so I
wrote and wrote and wrote and handed out
flyers I hustled I had two people in my
coffee shop first night and I sang a
five hour set and I sing my heart out
and what I learned is that I was very
lonely and a lot of people are lonely
and I deserved to be lonely because I
only told truth in one place and it was
in a notebook with nobody read and I
decided to take a risk and be vulnerable
and talk about what was real and not
hide from the truth and so I poured all
my feelings on from these two surfers
what their horse and so if you're
watching you know what opportunity will
come it is going to get ours back
through yeah and then the next week four
people came the next week seven I played
there every Thursday to try and have a
very regular time and then after about a
year it was filled out and people were
standing outside the windows standing in
pouring rain for five hours listening to
me through a window and a radio station
put a bootleg of mine on the air and
ended up requested and I got into the
top ten countdown down top ten countdown
on ie 1 X depending upon the biggest
stations in the country labels are like
who the heck is this girl on acoustic
guitar playing between
and Soundgarden they all started showing
up so it was like being Cinderella
you know limousines were showing up
really yeah and so you think I would
jump at the opportunity to have a record
label or a record deal except I had just
done happiness and I was not going to
give it up and fame as a path so many
people lose their footing on it happened
to be Rocky changing so much so you were
really trying to be careful yeah oh I
had to ask myself some very serious
questions why am i doing it's very
important to know if you want to end up
somewhere yes to know where you want to
end up then you have to have a compass
of knowing how to navigate so for me is
it an artist or famous I know I wanted
to be an artist nothing against fame by
the way it's just which one do you want
it's an experience for your life I
wanted to be an artist so every day and
my decisions based on being artist not
being famous or rich and the other is
kind of interesting caveat is I was
offered a million dollar signing bonus
and I turned it down I had read a book
called everything you need to know about
the music business and I learned that it
was in advance and that you owed the
advance back I knew I was going to make
a folk record the heights of grunge I
knew the odds of that working were
incredibly slim and so I basically
bought my own right to make my own music
and I negotiated the biggest back end
anybody had ever been given a royal
tease and mechanicals and thing I do is
crush it nice I love it
I did what I feel funny yet better
yourself I'll grind it if you're good
enough bet on yourself and I turned down
reality TV shows and a lot of short cut
things that there's no shortcut to being
great so I did 600 700 shows a year and
I did it for years and I grinded it out
and ended up breaking - but yes I've
always looked at myself entrepreneurial
II anti-spin and I really ran through
it's great it's really great it's real
you know it's funny I'm sure these four
and a lot of people watching or smiling
because so much of what I've been
talking about for the last 17 years have
so many of these something I saw on your
wall is coming in was about how many
people come to your funeral I've
actually made all my decisions in my
life what I call my deathbed decisions I
pretend I'm on my deathbed even when I
was a young child you know 17 18 and
said will this matter to me am I just
is this important this is the best
feeling for you as the person that
decided like hey these two people's like
you like are you finding a lot of
gratitude like that are you like are you
just like so pumps in the last 48 hours
people like you care about living love
deeply meaningful and equal and here
talking alone it's one thing to have
some philosophical things it's another
thing to have like the exact like me I
know it's like yeah it's really cool I'm
really really glad I got to meet you
thanks Andy let's do the first questions
cool
it was carolina carolina half jewel why
do you think so many people struggle to
be happy because happiness is a
byproduct not an actual destination and
so people have this misconception that
they're going to find happiness like
it's europe and they're never going to
move out and happiness is a byproduct of
certain behaviors and you can set
yourself up to win and you can set
yourself up to be happy the sad thing is
happiness is a learned skill and a lot
of our houses don't teach happiness that
was the situation I was in so I actually
started studying people that were happy
and I felt what the algorithm was what
do they do that's similar and for me I
don't focus on happiness as much as
harmony I don't really believe in the
word balance because balance is a binary
thing like oh you it's a very you know
tedious like a harmony is saying my life
has many components and the woman I'm a
mom I am sexual I'm spiritual and a
business person all of those limbs have
to have tone and that brings about
harmony that brings left satisfaction if
you only have one limb that is very buff
in the rest of this is atrophied we have
disharmony we have dissatisfaction but
there's no human school and so that's
what I'm looking at starting I want to
be able to teach people emotional and
mindfulness skills so that they can
grain gain tone in every area for my
standpoint you know since you will took
it up here I will take it into one very
narrow place that I've been really
trying to spend a lot of time on and
that's perspective it's so interesting
to me why I deem myself happy because I
just am so grateful like things like the
thing we got excited about of you know
the data but the data behind being a
human being is 400 trillion to 1 when
you just start there and you realize
forget
the odds of like beating homelessness
like other like or being born in the
communist country like just actually
becoming a human like like I always make
a joke about your mom could have had
another glass of wine and like like you
know it's like for your dad could be
late and because of traffic the odds are
so insane I'm just so grateful for what
I have versus what I don't have and I
think people just have all these
admirations and envy and all these cards
piling things to me it's per spekt
adjust like there's full I just
genuinely believe there's always
somebody that has it worse and the
problem is that's where I default into
mentally and have practice to put myself
there versus somebody's got it better
and the importance of gratitude is I do
a better to practice every night and
when you're grateful you can't be angry
you can't be resentful it literally just
leaves no room for anything else I'm
just grateful that all right in Alan
Alan asked how do you feel the future
musics going to be how and where you
earn most of your money I'm actually
very excited by the disruptive music
space it's deserved to be disrupted for
really quite a long time and it's
deserved to fail and I say that with all
all kindness and you mean the people in
the middle having disproportionate
economics yeah if I could do a brief
history of music and musicians spent a
long time understanding who they were is
and what they offered his musicians
people call that a brand now but there
were natural brand creators and so Led
Zeppelin stood for something you know
loving a musician was like an ethos it
was an entire culture and they were
culture builders and they spent years
cultivating that culture on the road
radio came along and it just super
boosted things and there's a really
golden time there for when that happened
and then radio became so powerful people
realized hey I don't have to have a
whole rate record I can have one good
song and then the record labels like and
we can charge for an entire record with
only one good song and the consumer
started going hey screw you guys I'm
getting ripped off this is a sucky
record with one good song to enter the
digital age and people could say okay I
only have to buy one good song but a
person like wait a minute
Napster I'm up on [ __ ] yeah
I'm streaming I don't personally feel
that music will be monetizable in a very
foreseeable way I think that we should
focus on musicians as brands and we're
lucky enough to use music as our brand
builder as our calling card and the
teach of the music business is learning
to build brands around artists that
artists have to have equity in yes you
know obviously the monetizing of live
event I thought so I think access is
where all the magic is because the
limited resources right so whether that
means in a show or one on ones or the
brands they touch I mean look it's funny
to hear you go with the brand move of
the equity thing you know when you think
about the economics 50 Cent's made just
a sponsorship deal of vitaminwater let
alone what you're seeing now we're you
know celebrities and musicians are
getting 5 10 15 30 % of a business
before launches on the back of their
brand it's a very entrepreneurial answer
but it's a truth it's at least to the
bottom of control of those economics and
we'll ask how did you choose up social
media access when it comes celebrity
privacy that's a good one I love it and
control of it and I've always really
welcomed it as I've lived my life with
transparency and it hide nothing and
that said I always honor their we love
[Music]
giving all the answers that nobody like
nobody else's yeah and what's weird is
it's one thing for me to say that came
and grew from it you were real real
famous when it came along so it didn't
even more impressive answer you know I
was the byproduct and benefited from the
transparency group in there but for you
to be where you were and love it speaks
to that rare authenticity well I also
was able as funny I was kind of college
textbook frame where the grass marketers
of one of the four founders of
grassroots marketing online wasn't
present me it was my fans and it was the
early days of the internet but it was
the reason I broke through grunge but
your fan it was your fan I mean I was
there I was doing the Wine Library thing
that's why I was so excited we talked a
little bit about this the other day like
your fans got there and gave a crap
because of you and then they took over
when you mean what my fans do now is
insane the level of love but it starts
with I love them first you have to love
them first maybe
second and all honesty I think people
and what I've been it's just been
incredible I had no mailman I get to
talk to my family directly and tell them
who I am I don't have a journalist going
you know the truth about Jules bla bla
bla bla and it's not true I figured to
tell people it's true I guess have that
direct relationship and not to mention I
should be a gift in we're all a gift in
each other's lives if I'm not a gift in
the life of my fans I'm not doing my job
this isn't all about me and so the way
technology is evolved it's much easier
for me to watch my fans see how their
families are doing encourage them to be
supporting one another I love it amazing
Andy I love it too lokah a back to
social media overall to a positive or
negative impact on the result that is a
question that's a great question
yeah it's something you and I were
talking about I think that my job as an
artist has always been to look at
culture and look at site-geist where is
culture swinging and where do I
authentically intersect with that for me
I'm great at connection and I love the
technological age I love how accessible
information is I love that we have
education or fingertips
I love that it's disrupting everything
it does have a tremendous ability to
cause a distraction addiction and need
to be careful with our children arm with
ourselves of how we consume now what
does that mean it's a very interesting
topic how do we consume in a way that
doesn't hurt our mental health that
doesn't cause neural pathways of
addiction and distraction addiction and
that's actually a very fascinating topic
I think the thing that a lot of people
talking about son Finnick has a video
that's gone viral in this way now I
think the question becomes that we never
do is what was the alternative so you
know it's one thing to say that we're
addicted to this and we're spending our
time on this my question is that same
human being what would they have been
doing with this time in 1989 would they
be addicted to television I had plenty
of friends who played 11 and a half
hours of Nintendo you know we're
deploying our angst against the medium
and we're not looking at the human being
enough like that you know there's a lot
of there's a lot of kids sitting in the
room on their phone all day long
creating Instagram accounts and doing
stuff that would have been on the street
doing something bad like there's this
thought that like it's all bad it's very
fascinating to me
I don't know I am unbelievably Pro human
being
I mean that could just data and behavior
and patterns like we're still here
like we've we've had all the ability
like when you think about what we could
be doing to each other negatively we
have all the power so much carnage could
happen to one second and we don't and so
we we are scared of what we don't know
and and I think that I think that I'm
surprised by the collective cynicism of
the American market for sure
around these technologies but it makes a
lot of sense to me because every time
there is a massive communication shift
we are very cynical of it yeah and we're
find weird but what I love is the
Millennials already have the antidote so
they're already a product of the culture
of being you know having the ability to
do this and look at the screen and what
are they telling us we want experiences
we don't want things that's the antidote
we get to get out and have experiences
so it's an antidote right guys this is
nothing compared to be yard twenty years
what people have sit in their home
they're the same again
they put their contact lenses on and
they'll be gone this is um this is it
like be happy but they're actually out
at about looking at their phone because
they're going to be in San Diego in a
pod and they're not coming out yeah and
these lemmings really though because
because by the way the your point and I
see where you're going it's why we've
always loved reading books and watching
what we need to escape for our mental
health that's what this is it becomes
the alternative universe the much more
extreme version of that is going to be
the virtual reality world when they can
absolutely in 20 years technology put in
contact lenses and be somewhere good a
lot of people talking about mindfulness
and you know about being in your head
it's actually not about we do need an
escape our minds will run us they hijack
us and so a lot of us use escape so that
we don't so we can escape our minds I
look at our bodies like an amazing
machine and it's an amazing machine our
brain is actually not the driver it's
the steering wheel so who's the driver I
think it's our observer when we get so
caught up in our mind we're desperate
for an escape
that's where mindfulness tools come into
play with how we interface with
everything you have to give yourself a
break from your mind
this healthy habit and not just
constantly a discretional just because
they're so beautiful what I want to ask
you for me I'm being from being selfish
now I don't know the answer I'm curious
your perspective I don't even escape I
don't want to escape I'm SuperDuper
pumped okay like I mean it like I'm even
scared to do meditation this is real
because I'm so happy with my mental
state that I don't want to do anything
that we jiggers anything and I never
need to escape from anything like I'm
super it's true and like I deal with
plenty of stresses and things that I
don't know I like it it's fine it's part
of it I don't know what do you think
about that yeah yeah like have you seen
that like how do you think about that
it's just interesting to me that like I
don't gravitate towards and escape at
all I don't want to I want to stay in my
head all the time yeah it's cozy what's
that like [ __ ] awesome all right dad
cool regards one last one maybe bad what
is one simple thing we can do to help
stop the stigma around mental health
that's taking into a different place
right mental health issues versus
meditation but that's what he's asking
we think about that well mental health
is a really broad scope so how would we
define mental health with the top very
narrowly about something anxiety
something a lot of people to number one
thing I hear people talk to him about
anxiety and I think that's a mental
health issue and I do think one of the
best antidotes to anxiety for me when I
was having Penn Texan and anxiety about
was learning to be mindful which was
just learning to be president right now
and I did it by following my hands
around on the day and it let me not
worry basically because I just forced to
be present and so it was actually a
really profound tool for change for me
to people affected and debate iago him
before we get into no yes brilliant
agenda and I've dumped by the way I've
done an incredible job not interrupting
I know all of you watching a crust it
I pray already commenting I crushed it
biting nails I never can you know I've
ever like I'm so curious what
you know anything about like if you look
at your hands to look like this biting
nails something that I'm listen I got
you and she knows her [ __ ] I'm excited
here your what a biting else do you
think that's a that's a move
you haven't had like the way you did
that am I so at peace and pumped because
I bite my nails all the time like I'm
trying to figure out what that means
like do you by any other yeah when I'm
when I'm really in like an interesting
spot like I my guess is that's how
you're handling a type of anxiety you're
going to think and you're going to
figure things out and that's your way of
doing it I don't know if you're mindful
while you're doing it or if it's an
absent set up in my book I'm just not
I'm just like waiting Spock I'm eating
we're having you know yes I keep going
go control yourself some mindfulness
with you oh I'm eating my nails get
curious about it
just observe it that's mindfulness and
it takes you from being you know
hijacked by your brain
to going back to being the driver yeah
I'm in control my brain cool yeah I feel
right here now you don't know why well I
respect that but that's only a micro one
example on a macro level anyway so
you've got done that done I think under
mental health issues like them and so I
think it's a really important thing to
focus on you know learning to calm our
anxiety learning about mental health
does nothing but help our entire culture
and multitude of ways and so I would
encourage both sides of the aisle to
start looking at mental health
mindfulness mental health solutions
instead of talking about highly
polarizing things look at the people
call public stigma around the solution I
do and I often have people say like why
do you how do you talk about all this
isn't I'm scary and I look at them
though have you ever not felt anxiety
jealousy fear like as am i inventing a
new emotion somebody's never come up
with no I don't know why people don't
talk about a enormous progress in the
last half decade this was not even being
talked about ten years ago this was zero
I'll get a pre-taped interview for the
Today Show and we were talking about the
movie that's coming out and she said I
looked at your website she talked to me
about mindfulness the entire time that
would not have happened to me five years
ago
two years ago I was flabbergasted
flabbergasted two points tell me two
seconds about this when did this come
out what's the basic theme and
we get up thank you yeah this is never
broken it's my memoir people always ask
me how I went from an abusive background
to moving out at 15 to being homeless to
being okay I didn't have access to
therapy I didn't have the funds or
resources and so I figured things out
and I wrote it because I want everybody
know that happiness is for everyone it
doesn't depend on the right husband the
right spouse the right house the right
anything you can literally do it when
you're homeless and I wanted people to
know that too awesome and my website
jewel never broken com shares very small
doable mindfulness tools that you can
incorporate so well every time we have a
guest
they get to ask the vaynernation a
question then we get thousands of
answers in facebook and youtube how cool
so now putting you on the spot which
because I wasn't pretty confident about
a regular askgaryvee show or watcher
okay what question do you have that
you'd like to get answered maybe get
some feedback where you get some
interesting insights to something that
might be on your mind
yeah I would love that let me think
about it my assumption without doing a
ton of research is that everybody's very
interested in personal empowerment and
entrepreneurially manifesting their
dreams would that be accurate
so I guess I would ask you guys I am in
the same situation and the music
industry there's a tremendous shift and
when I talk to most of the record
business about building equity around
myself around my ethos and the messaging
most people look at me kind of walking
crazy and say what are you go in the
road so whatever you guys know about me
I'd be very curious what your
entrepreneurial business ideas are for
me be frontally awesome
thank you thanks for being on the side
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
I am going to start talking like it is
awesome
[Music]
you
[Music]